on Christmas Day the Sistine Chapel and
Vatican Museums are closed in observance
of the holiday but earlier this year
Michelangelo's masterpiece and one of
the most iconic churches in the Catholic
faith came to life in digital form a
dynamic production that infuses history
with modern special effects launched in
a theater just up the street
the musician sting composed the theme
song John for a multimedia theater
experience that offers a new perspective
on the Sistine Chapel painting the show
was created by director who previously
designed Olympic ceremonies all with the
Vatican's permission Seth Doane scored a
ticket to go behind-the-scenes he filed
this report from Vatican City good
morning and Merry Christmas the Vatican
is always festive during the holidays
but the most elaborate decorations here
won't wilt in fact they're centuries old
the Sistine Chapel which is just over
there is visited every year by about 6
million people and now in a theater just
down the street there is a way to see
Michelangelo's masterpiece up close and
in digital form lasers lights
and a thunderous sound system
ad distinctly modern dimension to a
story that's roughly 500 years old
Michelangelo painting the Sistine Chapel
images filled the theater it's an
immersive experience that even its
creative director
Marco Ballack as a third time describing
it's easier to say what is now there is
ballet but it's not a ballet there is a
lot of beautiful music by John Metcalf
and sting but it's not a musical it's a
very technological show
ballots treated Michelangelo as a sort
of superhero whose frescoes in digital
form turned Rome's former Symphony Hall
into a second Sistine Chapel what did
you think those in offense it is
spectacular ballets has had some
practice staging a spectacle notably the
closing ceremony of the Sochi Olympic
Games usually we do a one-off so we is a
hey tiger soon and it's finished and
it's gone this this time it keeps going
I open up the door to the fakest inch
lettuce peak backstage to see how the
show works what the cast where and how
he took inspiration from spectacles the
Catholic Church has staged this is the
coffin of john paul ii which for to me
which I love ceremonies that was one of
the best ceremony ever done that which
takes images that visitors strained to
see in real life and expands and
animates them be pushed to create this
production and got the blessing of the
Vatican
that one skeptical Italian columnist
wasn't so nice calling all of the
special effects visual viagra when you
hear critic say this is just too much
it's all show they told me every time
they said oh but he's like Disney and I
said but Disney well Disney is a genius
what's wrong with it
creative director Marco Bala tells us he
gets some of his inspiration from the
immersive world of theme park rides and
says he knows he's been successful when
he looks around to see audiences
enthralled and not on their cell phones
for CBS this morning Seth Doane Vatican
City Seth Doane in Vatican City we thank
you